it really hit home that uh you know the
utility of money changes as you age it
really becomes
you know useless because the number of
activities that either you enjoy doing
or can do declines
right like and and this is just a
natural thing and i used to think oh not
me i'm going to be
swinging from the chandeliers in the
club when i'm 70. you know what i mean
and i look at my grandparents i'm like
oh who am i kidding those uh you know i
call them chuck e cheese tokens that
those dollars you have the
the the chucky cheese tokens for
partying or ski trips or doing this
whatever they expire
right as you age and they become useless
and what i mean is that
a certain amount of your money just
becomes useless to you it's not it's not
it's not it doesn't fulfill you the same
way it could have or at least the
activities that fulfill you start to
disappear
[Music]
i am pumped to welcome to ford
world class poker champion
best-selling author of the book in my
hand die with zero
getting all you can from your money and
your life hedge fund manager epic
investor bill perkins welcome to forward
bill
thank you thanks for having me i'm glad
to be here
holy cow was this book a joy to read
i learned a ton from it learned a lot
about you too and you and i have been
friends for a little while now uh but
one of the things i didn't realize is
that you went to the university of iowa
and wow did i spend a lot of time in
iowa
exactly
for for different reasons right but yeah
go hawks yes go go hawks so how did you
wind up at iowa as a kid who grew up in
new jersey
well my dad went to school there he he
was uh recruited under scholarship in
the 50s late 50s to play football there
that was pretty much a slacker i didn't
know where i wanted to go what i wanted
to do but i'd be going to iowa when he
went back to revisit for reunions and so
i just kind of
went to iowa that type of thing you know
no real direction in my life except for
all right this is the next step gotta go
to college you know that type of thing
uh well you graduated with a degree of
in engineering uh you played football
there too is that right
yeah i mean i was on the bench but yeah
i was on the team i mean that's a high
level team what position were you yes
uh i always say left out but i was a
defensive back
so you occasionally got to
hit on somebody uh and then you moved to
new york and you had like a very very
junior trading position you said you
were making 18 000 at the time you're
like a clerk yeah it was between 16 and
18 but i was a clerk it wasn't even
trading i don't even want to say trading
like it's uh you're a screen clerk which
is essentially you check the trades of
the traders and make sure they match
what's in the computer system back in
the pick card days if you've ever seen
trading places where people are throwing
pieces of paper etc at these guys with
glasses on to protect them from these
cards those cards have their trades that
they've traded with somebody in the pit
goes down to a room
they type in the trades and then they
have to match those what's on the
trader's pad my job was to check those
trades you were the match sandwiches and
stuff like that yeah
the equivalent of the mail room well
slightly below the mail room type of job
yeah so your book talks about when you
were in that job you scrimped and saved
and managed to eke out like a thousand
bucks in savings and you were all proud
of yourself um yeah which by the way i
can relate to because i'm the son of
immigrants and my family's super stingy
uh and so when i was younger i would
have similar habits and similar pride
being like ooh look i've saved a little
bit of money and then you mentioned to
your boss and this is one of the stories
in your book that really hit home you
said hey i managed to save a thousand
dollars and your boss is like what are
you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah
like he was just i was talking to
somebody else he's sitting over here i
was like are you [ __ ] idiot and just
kind of like you know
slap me across the face like what are
you doing saving a thousand dollars on
the meager salary you have like you
should go go enjoy that money you didn't
come here
to make a thousand dollars you came here
to make millions right like why why are
you why are you depriving yourself you
know that type of type of mentality and
it kind of just like made my head
explode you know i was kind of dejected
at first and i was just like it's kind
of right like what am i doing you know
yeah so this is principle number one in
your book um maximize life experiences
which is something that maybe people
hear but they don't really think about
uh and this advice from your boss led
you to kind of
go the other direction maybe a little
bit excessively you say or you're like
yeah yeah i was kind of yo-yoing i
wasn't it's kind of oh great right i
shouldn't be saving money so just like
spend it all and have all the fun i can
possibly have right like and have you
know no safety buffer no you know
no no savings whatsoever just kind of
spend every single nickel i made
um but
it got to the point and got me thinking
about yeah like
when am i going to spend money when am i
going to save money what's it going to
be for kind of kind of that type of
thinking you know what's it all for
like uh and and if i'm going to make
money in the future what am i going to
spend that on and that type of thing so
it started that process along with some
books i read uh your money your life etc
yeah so that's one of the big lessons
from your book uh is that life is a set
of experiences and a set of memories
and that memories have dividends which
was not an idea i'd ever seen until
reading your book can you explain what
the heck you mean by memory dividends
when you when you have an experience
right you you get joy from that
experience right you plan it you have it
and there's and
it's like great i i went swimming or i
had my first kiss or i went on this trip
and you get joy out of that but you also
get joy
and experience recalling it so uh my
first kiss if i talk about that it's
gonna be a story i'm gonna have some
sort of endorphins go from that talk
about them and remember it fondly or
when i talk about a vacation that i went
on like hey i went on this trip we went
to thailand and we saw all these statues
and yada yada lost my car keys and then
we were stuck and you know tell jokes et
cetera these are the things that make
things interesting you know at the very
basic level
the experience of learning what a door
is
allows you to approach every single door
and not go okay cylindric cylindrical
object two inches out
rectangle you know it's a door from your
experience right when you ride a bike
you're actually getting the memory div
and the next time you get on a bike
right like you you actually
build up who you are and your skill set
and you get the enjoyment of riding the
bike the memory of riding a bike and the
ability to go do it again and so
if your fulfillment is having
experiences and that joy that comes from
that experience
you get a portion of that every time you
recall it
every time you you bring it up right and
that's also part of your fulfillment and
so
these experiences pay dividends the same
way a stock would pay dividends or
interest in a bank would pay dividends
and this is something you need to
calculate when you decide
when you're going to have an experience
whether you're going to have
gratification now and take one trip or
delay gratification for say 10 years and
take two trips
right
and and you need to calculate well
i may only get one trip but i get all
the memory dividends associated with
that trip for 10 years building up
fulfilling me as opposed to waiting for
two uh 10 years and the answer may be
different uh depending on who you are
right if i'm 80 i'm not delaying
uh 10 years to take two trips i'm taking
the trip right now or even 70 right like
because my ability to even enjoy that
trip may go down as well
yeah you talk about your
similarly situated roommate in new york
who decided to take a trip i think it
was a very significant trip you went
like backpacking around europe even
though you guys were both broke uh and
and you were like man you can't do that
or i can't do that uh and so then he
goes on this trip while you're toiling
yeah yeah i thought he was [ __ ] nuts
because he actually borrowed from uh
from uh i would say a loan shark
to go go go on this trip which was like
this is the most irresponsible crazy
thing what are you talking about our
careers and we got we can't miss screen
clerking we might miss our chance to get
promoted and all this yadda yadda yadda
yadda stuff and so
he he went off
had the trip of a lifetime uh at the
right time too because
you know there's a time and a season for
everything in your life so he went
backpacking through europe travel around
was on tr you know student passes and
youth hostels and meeting people and
having this real dynamic trip that's
something that you know i'm not going to
have happen in my 40s and 50s right or
even late 30s when when i started making
more money although i went to europe
later and had a good time it was a
different type of trip
right and he had that type of experience
in the right time frame and so
if i wanted to have that in my life
i just let it go by
and i wanted to have that in my life and
i let it go by and i i realized like wow
he did it right i did it wrong
i i was operating too fear-based and
then it wasn't really thinking about
what experiences i wanted to have and
when in my life which you know what you
want to have in your life is is
important but also the when is equally
as important
yeah that's one of the big principles in
the book that i i took from it which is
that
experiences are worth different amounts
at different times in your life uh and
it's in part because this memory
dividend you're talking about but it's
also because like you said the
experience will be totally different
when you're 25 versus 30 versus 35
so he kind of got the 24 year old
version of that youth hostile europe
experience
[Laughter]
cue movie q movie
right yeah which by the way i never got
um yeah i never got
and so
uh but it did remind me of something uh
and so that this book was phenomenal at
making you examine your own life choices
so there was a period
when
a woman i was dating moved to europe
and i didn't have a whole lot of money
um and so i didn't like go and visit her
while we were still an item
and now i really regret it because if
i'd gone and visited her while we're
still in item then i would have had this
uh companion to explore continental
europe with uh and the rest of it but
instead i hunkered down and was sitting
there making money not even a lot of
money by the way
nothing nothing to write home about
right yeah yeah and then uh you know
then of course like the relationship
peter's out uh and then i lose that
opportunity um i still regret that to
this day i think to myself man you know
like that money was not that big a deal
like i could have made it made do i
wouldn't even have needed a loan shark
yeah yeah you know it's funny like even
now when i when i go travel i see all
these gapier students and they're
traveling or they're going to australia
to work in mcdonald's earning 25 an hour
because they pay a lot down there and
then they go backpacking through china
or or southeast asia and they have these
like super adventurous lives before they
go do college and i'm just like jesus
these kids are doing it better than me
you know what i mean like everywhere i
go i see someone having this adventurous
life that
i wanted to have when i was their age
and it's just like a constant reminder
like you missed out kid you missed out
you know
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
we all have been there at the cafe or on
the road where you log into an insecure
unencrypted network and you take your
chances you know you should be doing
something a little bit more savvy and
secure and protected but you're like
yeah what's the worst that could happen
unfortunately some really really bad
things can happen and one way to avoid
that is using expressvpn expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that hackers can't steal your data
you can just fire it up one button and
you're instantly protected and anonymous
it works like a charm i'm thrilled to be
endorsing expressvpn because this is
what a lot of companies use for their
employees to make sure that they're safe
secure and protected and you should too
secure your online data today at
expressvpn.com yang and get three extra
months free that's expressvpn.com
yang
expressvpn.com to protect your data on
the road or wherever you are
[Music]
yeah so you you tell the story too which
i i laughed out loud so your boss tells
you look
uh
you're doing it wrong you should not be
trying to scrimp and save you know a
thousand bucks if you're here to make a
fortune and you're like oh yeah you're
right so you start spending too much
and then you fall asleep at your station
and get fired
[Laughter]
but then you end up switching to uh
another job as a broker which is not
what you precisely want to do
um but that ends up leading you to a
role in houston texas where you are now
right and there are a lot of people that
might have hesitated about moving to
houston from new york especially if they
wanted to work in
you know training because like oh you
know like all the action is in new york
but then you looked at it and said oh
like like sure i'll make this move
and
uh there was like there were a couple of
principles in there
uh where
in your book you talk about trying to be
bold when you're young
and think about what you have to lose
because a lot of people
over emphasize what they might be
giving up uh and underestimate what they
might be gaining by writing a decision
right
they don't look at the opportunity cost
right like of the cost of inaction and
and i was one of those people that was
like i'm never moving south on the
mason-dixon line like what the hell
never go to texas like texas was like
rednecks and racists and cowboys and you
know i had this stereotypical image
largely informed from
uh past and tv right and you know i
didn't really know what texas was like i
hadn't been there but you know i was i
was like i had the texas of the 60s in
my head you know and so not not the
texas that it was when i moved down
there but fortunately for me
i was so passionate about uh becoming a
traitor and wanting to do it and and
this kind of like arrogant belief that i
could do it that i would have moved to
siberia i would have went anywhere i was
like what's the worst that can happen
you know i mean if they get me they get
me you know this and i and i made the
move and and luckily i had that attitude
about it uh
to do it and you know as i look at other
people in different careers i see people
like oh there's this job and you can
move here and they're like i don't know
i don't know anybody there i have to
move here etc and
a lot of jobs or opportunities go
unfilled
not necessarily that people can't do it
but they're not willing to take the
emotional risk of moving right uh
meeting new friends that that that
friction right and so they they stay in
a situation that may be less than ideal
or even painful like i say one of my
sayings is people will avoid pain to
live in misery and i'm not saying
everybody's a misery that doesn't move
but you know some gradient of that
happens
with that fear yeah you talk about a
sales clerk who
doesn't like her job and you're like hey
you need to leave because the fact is
you could get another job you don't like
you know immediately
yeah exactly
yeah and and that that rang true to me
uh a lot of and so the book has
different
guidance for people at different life
stages and for young people uh it's
around trying to
hone in on what you can gain from taking
action as opposed to what you might lose
and taking more risks when you have less
to lose like be bolder when you you have
fewer responsibilities
yeah the downside is is right like you
know at the end of the day when i was
like scripting and saving and and the
risk of the floors like i could have got
a job literally at a fast food
restaurant and got paid more right like
they purposely pay you low because of
the opportunity set that's there and
you're gonna go make right and so
going going you know and it's like i
could have been a waiter i could have
done any things like i was always going
to survive
uh you know survival wasn't an issue it
was just my ego of what was i willing to
do it when i fell down right and so
i should have been taking
you know max max max risk in certain
areas of my fight did in certain areas i
didn't you know in terms of like
emotional risk or taking a travel or et
cetera like i could have got another job
as a screen clerk and client the ranks
easily like i was one of the best screen
clerks to ever work
i'm gonna say that i'm just gonna say
that you know like so like uh you know i
missed out right i missed out on on that
something that can't replace that period
of my life has died that season is gone
and it is now either you know i i don't
either don't have the aptitude
or the attitude to go do it that way now
so you move to houston texas and become
uh an energy trader and end up being
very successful one of the big
principles of the book is around trying
to figure out what your
life experience money trade-offs are
when you're on autopilot and you're just
like hey i got good at this thing this
thing produces money i'm going to keep
money when money becomes the goal
and not the tool to fulfill your life
you just keep going on autopilot right
the purpose it's i always tell people
like
hammers and saws you can like make the
best hammers and saws but that's not the
goal the goal is to build a house but
some people get stuck just accumulating
hammers and salts hammers and sauces and
sauces so the money is a tool to to
enhance your life not the other way
around and so i think i think um even
even at all income levels right
you know people need to get to the
concept of enough and to know enough you
have to get off on a pilot like what do
i what experiences do i want in my life
what things are going to fulfill me
right
uh and then once you have that you know
exactly how much money you need
yeah you talk too about
time with your kids and you're you're a
parent you've got two girls right
right i've got two boys
um and that itself also is like a scarce
resource or a trade-off where if you
don't spend time with your kids during a
certain
year like you don't get that year back
uh and
and so there's also like an investment
in that regard it's like and you might
think to yourself oh i need to make this
money so that i can provide for my
family but
spending time with your kids actually is
an investment in them as well that in
some ways might be as or more important
and one of the things i love about you
and your approach to things like you're
so hyper rational about everything
[Laughter]
where
and we'll talk a little bit about this
where you don't stop with this book you
actually have produced a couple of apps
to help people optimize their time money
trade-offs but it instinctively made
sense to me that if you're spending all
your time and you make this point in the
book if you spend all your time making
money for the family and none of your
time actually with your family like time
spent with the family would have a much
higher return
[Laughter]
for the child
uh that than like another couple bucks
in a lot of
situations right if you look at money as
a tool to fulfill you right like it's
basically a tool for filming the first
the first
level is survival right and then after
that we're operating on a want basis not
a need basis so once the needs are
met we're operating on a want basis
and one of the things that your kids
want
uh whether they consciously or or or
unconsciously is time with you
memories with you moments with you and
so piling an extra million dollars on it
but taking away that time from you is
basically giving them something useless
right what they want is time with you
right and i'm not saying i have the
answer to the optimal balance right like
it's it's it's almost an intractable
problem but like these are the things we
need to think about
uh so that we get more close to the
optimal solution of balancing time with
kids or family members or loved ones or
or what have you yeah there was a lot of
wisdom in your book too about different
life stages where after you made some
money being a good grandson you give
your grandma ten thousand dollars
uh and then she doesn't do anything with
it uh and turns around and it gives you
like a sweater
yeah
exactly
sweater my mom corrected me she also
gave my daughter like a chain like a
small chain but like it really hit home
that uh you know the utility of money
changes as you age it really becomes
you know useless because the number of
activities that either you enjoy doing
or can do declines
right like and and this is just a
natural thing and i used to think oh not
me i'm going to be
swinging from the chandeliers in the
club when i'm 70. you know what i mean
and i look at my grandparents i'm like
oh who am i kidding like these are my
ancestors this is the way my even my dad
you know who was kind of out there and
you know they just
they just shift into gears and so uh you
know the the the wealth planners or life
planners say you know there's the go-go
years of the slogo years and the no-go
years and that's pretty much true for
universally true for everyone and so
those uh you know i call them chucky
cheese tokens that those dollars you
have the the
the chucky cheese tokens for partying or
ski trips or doing this whatever they
expire
right as you age and they become useless
and what i mean is is that
a certain amount of your money just
becomes useless to you it's not it's not
it's not it doesn't fulfill you the same
way it could have or at least the
activities that fulfill you start to
disappear
yeah so this is one of the fascinating
things you posit in the book which is
that there is essentially
an
optimal life period
during which money has the biggest
impact on your
enjoyment ability to have fulfilling
experiences
and that period is 26 to 35 years old
[Laughter]
i would say it's exactly that like you
reach mental maturity at 28 or at least
that's what the science says and
physical maturity at 33 uh and then
you're in then you're in plateau and
decline right and so
if
if your health so the book is a the
we're solving for net fulfillment and
the three variables are your wealth your
health and time right
and
if let's just say it was a simple
byproduct wealth times health times
whatever and the time you have available
is going there as your health declines
i got to throw more and more money at it
in order to get the same fulfillment or
the net fulfillment points right just in
a very broad broad sense and so
you know
that utility of money starts declining
declining declining declining
right as you go into decline and so
you know we're in plateau for a little
bit but you know right around 40 people
you know my back or oh i tried to play
pick up football and i sprained an ankle
yeah i mean you put your examples in the
book
but i'm 47.
and my
favorite time of the week used to be my
weekly basketball run
uh where there was a bunch of dudes that
are around my age
and
athleticism and skill and whatever um so
20 of us rented a court uh in new york
city
and we would show up every saturday
morning from 10 a.m to noon and play
uh and i would look forward to it every
week and
um there were times when you know i was
having a shitty day and i just think
back to you know a good play i made that
weekend it'd be like yeah
i still got it
so that so that during my 30s
uh people start dropping like flies
people start getting
you know ankles knees thumbs shoulders
like just freaking injuries start
happening when you're like 37 38 i
remember you know i showed up one time
we didn't have enough people who
and then pretty soon people like i'm not
doing that no more you know what i mean
like it just fades out right you know
there there's you know there's obviously
there's people on on different
tail ends of the distribution that keep
going and keep going and can do it but
by and large you know
these things become
you know
slightly less enjoyable slightly less
enjoyable i don't want to do it i can't
do it right like you know
and so
it's the same thing in terms of your
fulfillment like when you know i use an
example uh often that like when i go to
a city i like to walk around the city a
lot and i used to like knock out 10 15
miles a day walking around with a
backpack you know around paris et cetera
and now if i go to that same city it's
not that i can't walk 15 miles it's just
not enjoyable right so i'll walk seven
before my knees and my feet and i'm just
like you know i'm kind of done like i'm
not really so it's not the same trip i'm
not getting the same fulfillment points
from
that same plop down time in into into a
new city not that it's not enjoyable
it's just that if i was going to get the
max points probably should have done it
a little bit earlier right yeah and one
of the stories you tell in your book
that i found very invigorating
was that you planned an epic birthday
party for yourself
um where you got tons of people from
every
stage of your life together at caribbean
island and for some of them they
couldn't afford that kind of trip so you
were like you know what i'm going to
cover that trip for you
and it included your mother i believe
included like people that were deeply
important to you and you even this blew
my mind you even sprang
for natalie merchant that's the special
that's entertainment yeah for those who
don't know natalie merchant was uh like
uh
was the lead singer for ten thousand
maniacs and it's like this
you should check out her music she's
she's great uh
and you described it as memories that
would last a lifetime uh even though at
the time that expense was very very
considerable for you
um and i have to say man like i i
read these stories and i was like first
i wish i was your friend back then
because that would have been
freaking epic um but second it reminded
me of my wedding uh to evelyn where we
objectively
sort of overspent
honestly we had a destination wedding
but i don't regret it in the least
because it's still
maybe some of the the happiest memories
i have in my entire life
yeah it's definitely you know
one of the things i i discovered is is
that you don't you don't retire money
you're retiring your memories like you
invite people over you talk about the
old times or things that are going on or
or current visit with your grandkids or
or loved ones and so
these are the things and when you go out
to dinner or you you meet new people
whatever like most of the time you're
talking about things that have happened
to you or with them etc it's about the
past the experience you have so you're
building a richer life a more fulfilling
life and and that's your concept of self
and your enjoyment comes from these
experiences and so i like curating
very very rich deep loving meaningful
experiences and fun ones like you know
fun experiences to
to you know that's what gives me
fulfillment it might be something
different for somebody else but i find
that to be true
you know more often than not across the
board so
one of the pieces of advice you have in
the book that i a thousand percent
believe in because i did a version of
this
is to write things down that you want to
do
within certain what you call life
buckets and i didn't do it by life
buckets i just wrote down a list of
things that i want to achieve or want to
experience
and there is some magic to writing goals
now
any time i had the opportunity to hit
one of those goals i was like well i
guess i got to do it because that's on
the goal list
[Laughter]
right
so yeah i i talk about that like
one is
each purity in your life because you
know while your kids are like toddlers
or et cetera
you you can't just write them down oh i
want to take them to disney world
because they're going to be like dad i'm
not going to disney world with you when
they're 20 right and so the time the win
matters as much as as the what uh and
the other thing you know i talk you know
talk when i talk with groups or stuff
like that is kind of like
especially professionals like they have
all these uh key performance indicators
like you know ebitda uh customer
acquisition cost versus lifetime value
all these ratios et cetera for their
business and if their employees didn't
know these ratios who were in charge of
that they would fire them and i go well
what are your key performance indicators
for your fulfillment for your life
for for for your wife your marriage
crickets right they don't know it's
crickets it's crickets and i'm like are
you guys [ __ ] idiots
seriously like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you guys you know what i mean and
they've given me permission to talk to
them like they're my best friend so it's
a lot of fun and i'm just really
emphasizing the point that life is
serious and that if you were taken as as
serious as your business you would have
these indicators right like i have the
indicators like how much i've given to
charity i i check with my cfo what's the
percent if the percent is too low
i i've i boom dave thomas foundation
here you go adoption services here you
go you know
starvation in yemen here you go you know
the things that are important to me
other people have different things how
many trips have i taken i just know
instinctually if my travel budget is is
below x that i'm doing something wrong
you know something's going on right it's
something for me to investigate further
how many i love you have i said how many
times have i done this how many times
have i gone out to dinner with my wife
now wife
yeah congrats on that man you can make
any kind of kpi you want according to
who you are like if you love playing
chess and checkers well how many times
have you played chess and checkers right
yeah writing goals down helps you
uh achieve them almost magically and so
i i really do advise people to do it
whether it's in time buckets uh the way
bill's describing uh or
even more generally
because you'll just find yourself
behaving differently yeah and not but i
want to add to that writing them down is
great
but also
the check the metric did it happen yeah
right like you write like i'm gonna
practice and play basketball and shoot
threes every day like i'm gonna take i
don't know ten
ten three-point attempts every day
whatever and if you end at the weekend
it's still zero it's like well we need
that feedback right yeah yeah you all
need feedback right and so
and it's your life nobody's here to
rescue you it's your own life
a lot of people think like somebody's
going to come out and rescue you like
the fairy godmother's going to come out
it's like your own life so you have to
you have to monitor yourself and your
own feedback according to the goals in
life you want to live and and have these
key performance indicators on your life
so whether that's you know
i love you count or how many times you
took your your significant other out on
a date or it's you know how many trips
you went on or how many times you play
chester checkers whatever it is we need
to track those results to see that keep
us on on path or how many political
candidates around the country you've
elevated now i'm kidding
exactly whatever it is whatever it is
it's like how many donors have you
called you know it's like i gotta call
this guy
how did you know that that's my life but
anyway i mean
these things are you know the same
things that you use in business uh you
can use in your life for your life
fulfillment and i think one is more
important than the other
amen i mean that's one of the big
principles of this book is like it
really is like it's like a rational
approach to making the most of your life
i i hope so what are your apis there you
got your kpis out there andrew i mean
you're thinking of something that you
need to get down out there yeah i could
use more your own scorecard your own
life scorecard yeah my my life scorecard
and like you said it does evolve over
time because um but i need i need to
refresh and review it because i had it
and then
i haven't refreshed it properly and
unfortunately my life stage has changed
that's another thing we all do and
that's why i have a buddy i have an
accountability buddy i i call him up and
he's you know he slaps me around i'm
like okay i'm with autopilot back back
to it back to it you know it's very easy
to get into the default mode network and
just go on autopilot so don't don't act
like i don't want to act like i'm the
guru and i'm some here up high i'm right
down there with you i'm a student of the
game of life just just as everyone else
is
[Music]
one of the the curves you describe is
that people
work they earn money they save money and
then they get to a certain point and
most people after they save a certain
amount amount of money they're actually
not spending it down like they get to a
certain point and the money's going up
even as their ability to enjoy it goes
down and their consumption is going down
because
because maybe their energy level is less
so their
uh desire to travel is lower
uh and so one of the
situations you describe is this and
we've all heard this story um where
there is like uh
uh
an elderly woman who's just toiling for
years and years and no one knows that
she's actually secretly wealthy
and then she passes away and then uh you
know the non-profit gets five million
dollars and her relatives get yet x
million of people like wow like she
lived such a
modest life
um and and you make the point look um
that person's uh favorite charity could
probably use the money a little bit
earlier
like and very very importantly
their relatives often could use the
money a lot earlier because the average
age at which you inherit money from
uh your
parents is age 60 which often is a
little bit past like the optimal time
for you to get that money so if you are
someone who's saying like hey i'm going
to save this for charity i'm going to
save this for your kids you might want
to get a move on and actually just start
putting that money to work now yeah
particularly let's just start with the
kids like i think when people say yeah i
want to help out my kids i'm like well
they probably even when they say that
don't have a vision of their kids as
six-year-olds when they're gonna help
them out
that's not even a thing right like it's
not even a thing but i think there's
just like this cultural autopilot like
oh when i die what's left over is this
tip for the kids it's not really a
deliberate plan and thinking about when
is the most optimal time for them to
receive the money when can they convert
it you know when does it have the
maximum utility to them um and the same
thing with charities right like these
education charities particularly the one
in the book like the return on education
is massive i'm sure you know that it's
more than any return she can make saving
and so
the five million that she gave you know
that
was distributed from her estate to the
charity when she died you know even a
million 20 years ago would have been a
better deal right
500 000 right
um so
so you know i i have this sense of like
life is urgent and life is now and that
we need to optimize kind of like where
we want to have our impact and you know
um
you know particularly with your kids
like where where are you going to have
the most impact on their lives where
they're going to appreciate it the most
when they're going to need it the most
when is it going to be
you know you're basically saying when
you give them money you're basically
saying i want to give you the ability to
have experiences
so when it when are they going to most
be able to have the most experiences and
get the most joy out of it twenty six
nine thirty five brother
exactly it's not sixty i'm just gonna go
right on the record i'm just going to
say at 860. you know and and going back
to that chart like you can go look in
the bureau label statistics or etc about
those who save and household net worth
keeps going up in their 70s you know and
in the book i put a little thing like
what are they waiting for when's the
party just tell me when the party is
right like
when are we going to spend this [ __ ] you
know like you know and it's like like
would it and and and you know i joke but
i'm just kind of like it's pass them by
their ability to consume has passed them
by
and and
also their their their their attitude
about consumption and the type of
activities they like now has passed them
by just like
maybe you would have been like i'm going
to this three-on-three amateur
basketball tournament all over the world
and i'm gonna spend money on that or
whatever
and that period has passed you by now
you're like nah my ankle my back my
shoulder i'm done dude all i know is if
i come home injured uh and i can't do
[ __ ] around the house evelyn's gonna be
pissed
because
because for her the positive utility of
my like enjoyment of the game like you
know she discounts that entirely she's
like yeah yeah
what do you do to hurt yourself it's
very little value to her at all maybe
get you out of her hair for a little bit
and that's about it right
so yeah that so you cite the example of
this philanthropist and obviously not
everyone's going to be a philanthropist
but if you are unfortunate enough
position to do so and i'd love to hear
what your experiences have been kind of
spreading the word about this book but
you talk about a guy named chuck feeney
who champions living while giving where
he made a
ton of money on duty-free stories that
we all see in the airports um and right
and he just set aside two million
dollars to live on which is fine for him
because he's a normal dude and then he's
just giving the rest away while he's
still alive um and that's like a much
more powerful impactful model than just
having this giant slug of money that
ends up you know get getting converted
um on your estate yeah when you die and
like you know life is now like what
happens to the people it it seems weird
to me
like people are starving in yemen or
whatever and like i'm gonna wait till i
die you know i'm gonna hold up and grow
you know it's kind of or you know
imagine during polio like you know i'm
not gonna donate to the research in
polio and accelerate the the vaccine i'm
gonna wait till i die right like and
perhaps you know there were people at
that time that could have accelerated
that development and saved a bunch of
kids you know
at the time and so
that's kind of the way i'm approaching
it and thinking about it like life is
urgent life is now and and that the
return on your charitable dollar is
greater than any return that you're
gonna make and so
make make it you know
to the extent that you can
effectively give it now make that impact
now yeah another lesson from your book
that frankly made me feel guilty
was that investing in your health in
small ways pays off in huge
uh regards because you know you drop
five pounds now it like ends up keeping
you healthier for years and years and i
was like oh my gosh in part
because having met you in person you
kind of exude a certain degree of
vitality and health you bill perkins
like you're you know
like anybody who's watching this video
be like i have no idea how
how old this guy he's kind of got this
vin diesel indeterminate ethnicity and
determinate age thing going you do i
mean it's a compliment you look like a
movie star yeah thank you
but at 53 so yeah but it did make me
think i was like oh [ __ ] i gotta get
into shape because bill's right like if
you make investments in your health then
that ends up leading to more fulfilling
experiences yeah it's just compound it's
the number one variable right like you
can have
zero money and get value out of this
book because this book is about
optimizing your life so
do i spend time with my daughter or do i
go play basketball i do at the gym like
how do i order my life like life is like
tetris right in order to get the high
score you got to get the order right
right you don't you don't go out to the
club and climb in himalayas when you
have three kids at home and you're
married right like those were before you
got married right and so
but if you have your health is extremely
poor none of these experiences are
all the experience become less and less
enjoyable and to the point where you
can't move you have no experience right
then you die
and it's amazing when you try and model
it like small changes in health how
radically it changes your your enjoyment
or your fulfillment points any model
that you built
yeah the the book has lessons for
everyone like if you're young and broke
i feel like the lessons are
you know take some more risks like try
and drag the experiences forward instead
of being like yeah i'll do that later
um and then if you're a bit older and
more established it's like
like do you really just want to be
sitting on this pile of gold coins
as it's heading it's like you know you
say you're doing it with your kids it's
like well your kids are alive now like
you know maybe that you can do something
where and you make the point in the book
it's like if if you really want the kids
to have the money then make it their
money and not your money uh correct
yeah which made sense to me as well
yeah a lot a lot of people come with
that i'm like if it's still in your
account it's still in your state it's
not in the trust or you haven't given it
to them
you get an accident you get sued there
goes their money that was supposedly
their money it's your money and their
money right and so
uh
you know
you you really need to think about okay
kids i mean they're not 60. i just keep
saying it's not 60. you know what i mean
and and if you if you are lucky and and
the average is hold and you live to 84
86 or whatever your kids are
or 60 or late 50s that's not the optimal
time for them to have have any kind of
gift any kind of inheritance dude i did
what the book said which is i i put my
variables into a life expectancy
calculator
and apparently i'm going to live to be
90. so i was like i was like oh i better
start thinking in
these terms you you you you pit me a
little bit but you get to you get to uh
you get to like figure out all right how
now that you're going to live the 90
what experiences belong when like what
are you going to be doing 80 to 90 70 to
80
50 to 55 you know what experiences you
want to have both you know
charitable
emotionally
socially
you know family
business-wise career-wise politically so
you know we had to throw that out there
for you
you know that these so you get to you
get to think about like where the
experiences belong you know and and map
them out
uh well on the political side you've
been this awesome champion of third
parties essentially for quite some time
i think it's because you're kind of an
independent thinker
um super grateful uh for your
belief in what we're doing it forward
but you've also supported uh the
libertarian party um is this part is
this in part because you you've
uh been
attracted to those ideas uh or is it
because like you you just naturally
uh kind of have an independent streak
yeah i'm naturally like the hell [ __ ]
the system no no i'm i'm i'm i i think
the libertarian just like the principles
and philosophies and reading the old you
know it it it it it aligns a lot with my
beliefs a reason approach uh a balanced
approach uh
and and
you know i i find myself as like okay
i'm part of a relay race of life right
like we're not going to win the
presidential election next year or
whatever but my my job is to just
support it pass the baton on to future
libertarians or or or thought leaders
and until one day they can either get
their policies or or or or a person in a
position of power to actually enact
those policies and either one is fine
for me right like if you if you want to
be anti-war or low in the military
budget do these certain things either
one is fine it doesn't have to be our
guy
it just has to get you know these things
done because that you know it's better
for
i believe it's better for our people
planet nation etc and so the same thing
goes with with your party you know not
being
strapped into some sort of like
tribalism
uh you know well these guys came up with
this idea so we're against it you know
non-rational emotional type knee-jerk
response but very rational approach to
uh today's problems um and and and not
be
stuck with the dogma of these legacy
parties which is essentially like who do
you hate less
amen brother i mean you know like you
just said we just want good things to
happen and like whether it's because
we're they're like pushing good things
to happen or whether we're in there
making it happen as long as more good
things happen
in that yeah that sector uh will feel
like it's a job well done
um so you've put a significant amount of
effort i mean this book is a bestseller
so congratulations on that score there
there is a website anyone wants to check
it out uh diewithxerobook.com
um and you have various apps
out so that people can calibrate and
balance their
life choices which
again is is awesome and spectacular i
genuinely think of you as kind of like a
guru who's like trying to make people's
lives better
um by having them make more rational
less autopiloty choices so i'm wondering
if people have come to you because you
know i know you also speak in various
venues i've been like hey man like
this changed my life like i made
different decisions you must be getting
those stories all the time yeah yeah
that's a that's the you know you don't
write books to make money i'm sure you
know that
right like you could be a best knowledge
that doesn't mean anything you're not
going to see a nickel but uh but uh you
know the the the reward is is that
people come to me and like i i i would
have never done this because of you i'm
doing this i'm having the time of life
i'm in more fulfillment you've
crystallized what i've always known i've
given them permission basically like put
it laid it out for permission like how
they feel they should be living the move
and so
you know if if people just adopt a
little bit a little bit of what's in the
book just get off autopilot just a
little live intentionally just a little
um they're gonna have a more fulfilling
life and that makes me happy and so that
that feedback that i got from people
that have read the book
is is amazing every time someone downs
downloads the app you're like yeah i
help someone else live a little better
the apps are the mental models that we
put up for free mental models we put up
the the you know an app they're kind of
like magnitude trying to get you to to
prod you to start thinking about it
right like the book is very much in um
here are some ways to apply it but very
theory very in force equals mass times
acceleration or equals mc squared it
doesn't get you the gps right like you
got to apply you got to take out of that
formula what you want to take out of it
because everybody's priorities and lives
are different but if you get off
autopilot and you use these guidelines
these mental bottles i believe
everyone who does that will have a more
fulfilling life according to the life
that they want to have i just want you
more of what you want right yeah just
like a life better lived uh and and you
really do exude this stuff uh you know
when you talk about how your your mom
worked for the government and she was
like oh like you know get get a
government job we'll be super safe
[Laughter]
you've gone in a a very different
direction no no no i'd rather be you
know
my temperament is like i'd rather be
busted than do something like that i'd
rather you know i wouldn't hit the grave
with scars you know
heartbroken scars
attempts failures looking like a buffoon
you know having successes etcetera i
want i want to have a a very
wild adventurous fulfilling ride and to
me what's fulfilling is is actually
using up all your resources to get that
fulfillment to actually try you know the
the sports analogy is leave it all on
the field well you know here at life
this is it it's one ride you leave it
all in this life and that's it you know
and so
uh
safety of job just didn't really you
know
safe is
safe to me is misery
uh it's a it's a form of hiding from
life because life is dangerous just it
just inherently it's dangerous you know
what was fun too bill is that reading
your book
um
i congratulated myself a little bit
because i feel like i'd lived
uh according to some of the principles
without knowing them obviously um and
part of it was the
risk i
i took on when i was relatively young in
part because i you know i didn't have a
family or even a girlfriend
you know like no morgan so it was like
um yeah so so i've done a bunch of
things that people thought of at the
time as being kind of unwise including
my asian parents uh you know not fans um
and and certainly one of like the
biggest swings i took was running for
president
and people thought at the time i mean my
even close friends of mine were like
president of
you know
but i kind of
drew it out in my head and was like look
like you know what's my downside time
away from the family opportunity costs
total public humiliation and the upside
is like maybe i can advance human
civilization maybe i can help alleviate
poverty maybe i can like improve the
standard of living for
you know tens of millions of people uh
or shift the dialogue shift the dialogue
and get people thinking about it right
like
as far as i'm concerned like you could
you could have won you could have
shifted dialogue or you've picked up the
baton
run it and eventually pass it on to
somebody else and that race has started
and so like uh
you know in the relay game of right the
uh relay game of life you don't know
whether you're the anchor or the starter
yeah you just gotta run it's gotta run
and what you did is you ran you know
what i mean that's admirable thanks man
so there were parts of it where i was
like okay cool i'm like doing this stuff
i'm like you know like on the die with
zero train um but then there were other
things where i was like oh i need to do
more of that
uh certainly
um
i i feel like because i'm 47 like i need
to drag experiences forward to the
extent possible like anything where i'm
thinking like oh i need to do that it's
like oh i should freaking do that stuff
now because you know life is busy and
for me right now a lot of that is around
my parents who are
uh in their 70s and 80s and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i need to spend more time with them
now um like that like that that's you
know like that that's uh
not gonna last forever
uh
and for a young person it really is also
i think trying to drag experiences
forward
um because
like our society does give you a message
and you open your book which is what
we'll close with but you open your book
with uh the ant and the grasshopper
and you know the the ant is like working
uh tirelessly and collecting the
seeds or or food and then that's
presented as like the virtuous model and
the grasshopper is like the one who
uh like does something and then rests
and then ends up losing it's like the
slow but steady wins the race and our
society continuously kind of hammers at
like the oh like um and by the way also
like you know i'm uh
like a
son of
immigrants and asians so like i've
internalized a lot of those messages
uh but
people trying to max out their
experiences i kind of did it
accidentally because i didn't meet my
wife until i was 31 so i was like just
kind of wandering the earth before then
being like well like i guess i go
skydiving i guess i go hang gliding
go do things all right i mean life is
discovery you discover what you want
right you don't you don't know you so
you got to go to discovery so you did a
lot of discovery yeah but i'm so
thankful i did that stuff now and then
now you know it's like if i'm going to
spend a couple of years
um in
iowa and new hampshire running for
president like you know i'm like okay
it's cool like i feel kind of settled um
and i i feel settled in large part
because i did some of those things when
i'm young when i was younger
um so if you are young and broke try and
max out those experiences if you are a
little bit older try and drag some of
those experiences forward and try to as
my friend bill perkins says uh die with
zero get all you can from your
money in your life and don't go on
autopilot don't just think hey like i'm
supposed to have a pile of money that
increases and doesn't decrease so like
you know that's what i'm going to do
through my 50s 60s 70s like freaking get
it out on the field yeah leave it one
ride
hope you enjoy it you know i hope it's
the most adventurous it's funny that you
say asian um
um work ethic and culture because the
book is biggest in japan
you know really
that's right because it counted the
culture like it's like really big in
japan you know and they're like
wow this is so it's so foreign right uh
from from it's like you know this whole
kind of work work work safe safe safe
safe safe die give money to your kids
which generation ever has fun if
everybody's you know if everybody's just
grinding forever right it's like a
thousand years of grinding you know well
look at this man you're gonna end up
changing uh japanese culture
it would be great yeah and hopefully you
do
inspire people to live fuller richer
lives in the sense of uh of the truest
meaning of the word uh congratulations
for
uh putting this out and for living it
yourself man i mean you're you're a role
model for me and a lot of other people
i don't know if i'm a role model i mean
i wrote the book for me right like i was
like i'm just as on autopilot as the
next person you know i'm like i knew i
was like okay let me go back to the guys
i have an accountability buddy i'm like
okay we sit down and meet and like okay
what are you doing how are you spending
your time that type of thing so uh
uh but i i i hope i've inspired people i
wouldn't call myself a role model but i
hope i inspired people
you're one of the most uplifting guys i
i know bill and not just because you won
the world series of poker
i like that
but
thank you so much if you're listening to
this check out daiwazerobook.com
follow bill perkins on social media on
twitter he's uh at bp22
bill thank you so much for being an
awesome human being i will see you in
houston in september see you soon okay
see you soon thanks
[Music]
you